[Musique]
Bonjour, pas un journal télévisé depuis
quelques semaines dans lequel on entend
parler de l'affaire Clear Stream. Mais
Clearstream, c'est quoi ? Une lessiveuse
mystérieuse d'argent sale, la clé de
bien des affaires de narcotrafic, de
trafic
d'armes et ou de mondialisation et de
licenciement. Notre invité aujourd'hui
est Denis Robert, journaliste, écrivain,
artiste, auteur il y a 10 ans d'une
enquête sur Clearstream. Clearstream,
c'est une chambre de compensation
financière basée au Luxembourg qui était
alors inconnue du grand public et dont
il dénonçait les agissements troubles.
Aujourd'hui, tout le monde en France
connaît Clearstream. C'est devenu
évidemment synonyme de scandale d'État.
10 ans de bataille judiciaire, 60
procès, des centaines d'huiciers à votre
porte de solides inimitiés dans le monde
politique tout de même. Il en reste
également parmi vos nos confrères, le
milieu de la presse et puis un éclair et
puis la nuit après 10 ans. Voilà le 3
février 2011, c'est encore tout frais,
tout récent, la Cour de cassation vous
planche in définitivement et reconnaît
dans votre travail votre travail alors
de journaliste et d'enquêteurs.
Les finances de la presse, bah d'un
point de vue économique, c'est une
catastrophe au niveau de la presse
papier, ça c'est évident. Je je j'ai
j'ai déjeuné avec un ami tout à l'heure.
Les ventes du Nouvels par exemple ont
baissé de de les ventes du poids ont
baissé de 16 %. Le dernier trimestre,
celle de l'OPS ont baissé de 14 et
l'Express qui a fait dans lance a baissé
de 10. Libération est en situation
catastrophique. C'est même plus c'est la
respiration artificielle à leur niveau.
Le ça vient de quoi ? Ça vient de quoi ?
Ben ça vient de de ben il y a l'internet
qui est venu tout bouffer quoi. Et puis
ça ça vient aussi des contenus qui sont
à vendre qui qui correspondent plus on
va dire naïvement au désirs des
des lecteurs ou des gens qui payent des
gens. Est-ce que tu penses que c'est une
perte de confiance des lecteurs, des
auditeurs face à la presse en général ?
Face au métier de journalistique crois
c'est que d'abord il y a une offre qui
est considérable que l'information est
noyée dans cette offre donc c'est très
compliqué. L'actualité c'est facile,
l'information c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué donc il faut la recouper.
Enfin, tout ça, ça demande du travail,
du temps et puis euh euh comment dire le
le l'offre qui est proposée ne
correspond plus visiblement dans des
lignes très larges au désirs des des des
lecteurs ou des acheteurs de journaux ou
des abonnés. Enfin, donc on voit qu'il y
a une espèce d'affaissement comme ça.
Ceci dit, c'est pas c'est pas un drame,
c'est un mini drame. C'est c'est une
tendance, c'est lourd, c'est compliqué,
mais en même temps euh comment
dire, il y a une responsabilité des des
éditeurs, des patons de presse, des
journalistes. Donc je vais pas pleurer
avec tout le monde. C'est comme ça.
Voilà. Au niveau de la confiance, oui,
non, tu penses que la la population, le
le client de presse, est-ce qu'il a
perdu confiance dans dans sa presse ?
C'est difficile de répondre sur ce type
de question parce que c'est des
généralités. Je pense que d'une manière
générale, oui, je pense qu'il y a un
manque de confiance. Ceci dit, euh
l'affaire causac pour parler d'elle a
montré que que les les que que que quand
tu as une volonté journalistique forte,
tu arrives à à renverser des des des
pouvoirs et en même temps, c'est aussi
un contraison parce que c'est c'est la
médiia part, ils ont eu contre la presse
quoi. Et je les comprends.
Vous avez été auditionné aujourd'hui au
Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale et
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous leur
avez dit ?
C'est des c'est vraiment une mission
parlementaire sur le sur le journalisme
et la protection des sources, c'est le
point de départ mais c'est un peu plus
vaste que la protection des sources.
Donc c'est c'était une une conversation
qui a duré 1 heure où on m'a beaucoup
interrogé sur sur Clearstream sur et sur
les difficultés que j'avais eu
personnellement. Et si tu veux, enfin si
vous voulez une une de mes parmi les
idées que j'ai développé, en fait, on
peut pas on peut pas isoler le problème
de la protection des sources de
l'ensemble des problèmes de la
protection de du journaliste. Parce que
parler des sources, c'est parler des
problèmes de diffamation, de droit à
l'image, c'est parler de la loi gesso,
c'est parler de la liberté d'expression,
c'est parler de tout ça. Donc c'est un
tout. On est la profession est en perte
de repère, est en perte d'identité. En
même temps, le monde avance plus vite
qu'elle, quoi. Donc, il y a des il y a
des réjustements, il y a des règles, euh
il y a des tas de questions qui se
posent. Il y a des gens qui veulent
créer un ordre des journalistes, il y a
des gens qui veulent créer une espèce de
haute autorité de de la presse numérique
avec la la qui qui serait à l'instard de
la haute autorité de l'audiovisuel. Il y
a il y a des il y a des projets de loi
qui peuvent être hyper protecteurs pour
le journalisme qui se font au détriment
de de de d'autres choses de de de Il y a
aussi la les gens qui se sentent qui se
sentent insultés ou bafoués par des
articles ont le droit de se défendre.
Donc c'est une question d'une d'une
complexité assez importante et donc
c'est c'est ces députés essaient de de
de trouver un chemin dans tout ça. Ils
ont une démarche qui me semble cohérente
et honnête. Et en France, on est en
retard par rapport à des pays comme la
Belgique par exemple qui qui eux ont
choisi des chemins. Je sais parce que
j'étais entendu par des des commissions
en Belgique là. Ils veulent créer un
délit de presse qui est spécifique, ils
veulent il y a il y a des tas de trucs
qui circulent en ce moment et il y a des
et je pense que que François Hollande
indépendamment de tout le reste c'est
quelqu'un qui est beaucoup moins
liberticide que l'étais quoi, en la
matière. Donc donc la volonté c'est de
ces députés, je pense qu'ils sont
conscients que que qu'en ce moment il y
a des il y a des bouleversements, il y a
des choses qui se passe et que et que et
que on peut pas se contenter de dire
laissons faire les choses. Mais qu'en
même temps dès que tu touches à à un
aspect du truc, c'est c'est un truc qui
est très fragile parce que c'est ça
devient très vite liberticide ou ça
devient c'est la porte ouverte aussi à
toutes les les conneries qu'on voit sur
internet. Donc euh donc ils vous ont
beaucoup interrogé sur ClearSAM euh
parce que il y avait une méconnaissance
du dossier, il y avait une
méconnaissance de la technique
journalistique d'investigation.
Non mais ce qui se passe c'est que euh
moi je suis le le le parfait exemple. Je
pense qu'il y a il y a il y a pas
d'autres il y a très peu d'autres
exemples de de ce que ce que les
Canadiens appellent les procédures
bayons. C'est-à-dire que vous vous êtes
bombardé de procès et infin même si vous
gagnez vous vous vous perdez quoi parce
que le temps que vous passez à vous
défendre le
temps le le monde avance et puis il y a
il y a un espèce de rouleau compresseur
comme ça. Donc comment empêcher ces ces
ces plaintes ? Moi j'ai jamais dit que
même Clairstream même les plus pourris
des pourris ont le droit d'attaquer en
diffamation. C'est un jeu normal, il y a
une justice, les juges jugent, les
journalistes font leur job, les
écrivains leur enfin parce qu'après il y
a des problèmes de différence de statut
entre journalistes écrivain. Tout ça est
un peu compliqué aussi. Et en face, bon
simplement là on voit bien que quand on
est face à des des oligopoles ou à des
ou à des multinationales ou à des mecs
blindés de pognons qui qui se font
attaquer dans la presse que ce sur
internet ou dans les papiers, les types
déposent des plaintes, déposent des
plaintes et après vous êtes comme dans
une partie de ping-pong, vous avez
qu'une raquette, vous êtes face à à des
joueurs dans tous les pays, c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé. Donc comment empêcher ça
alors que légalement ils ont le droit de
le faire ? Donc moi, j'ai j'ai je pense
qu'il faut imaginer soit de changer la
loi sur la diffamation, c'est-à-dire que
de plus demander d'argent au
journaliste, il y a des choses à faire.
Mais moi ce que je préconise, c'est un
truc un petit peu compliqué, c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de défendre à
l'assemblée, c'est que quand ce que je
me suis retrouvé souvent dans ce cas de
figure de type qui vous qui vous
assennent des procès qui vous demandent
un maximum de pognon que quand en gros
je le fais court mais après il faut
trouver les termes juridiques. Quand
l'histoire vous donne raison parce que
ça prend toujours du temps, la vérité
les types qui vous demandent du blé bah
il faut multiplier par 10 par 20 par 100
ce qu' vous ont demandé au bénéfice du
du journaliste. comme ça, ils hésiteront
avant de déposer des plaintes et parce
que il y a un risque pour eux aussi
s'ils perdent parce que le problème des
diffamations, c'est que les types qui
dépose des plaintes quand ils perdent
euh ou quand ils racontent des
conneries, quand ils assennent des
accusations qui sont fausses, ben eux
s'en foutent ou même la veille d'un
procès, ils peuvent retirer leurs
plaines. Ceci dit, les dégâts sont déjà
là, quoi. Donc je je crois qu'il faut
être il faut être inventif sur ces ces
questions là parce que un des une des
des je vous donne un exemple dans à
Paris au tribunal dans le le le comment
dire la cour qui s'occupe des des procès
en diffamation il y a 3 ans le le il y a
pas 3 ans, il y a en 2000 au début des
années 2000 euh quand j'ai sorti mes
bouquins. Ça mettait en gros 2 ans de 2
à 3 ans entre le moment où quelqu'un
déposait plainte en diffamation et le
moment où la plainte était ou instruite
ou jugée. Il se passait entre 2 et 3
ans. C'est des très très longs.
Aujourd'hui, il se passe entre 2 et 3
mois. Donc on pourrait penser que c'est
la justice va mieux, ça fonctionne bien,
mais pas du tout. C'est parce qu'il y a
de moins en moins de procédures en
diffamation. Et il y en a de moins en
moins. C'est pas une bonne nouvelle.
C'est une très mauvaise nouvelle. Ça
veut dire que les éditeurs de presse ou
les journalistes ou les ont tellement
peur maintenant des même plus de perdre
des procès mais ils ont peur des procès
parce que les procédures cher qui
évidemment il y a une autocensure et il
y a une censure et ça c'est dramatique.
C'est-à-dire que la la liberté
d'expression et et les la démocratie
souffre de ça. Donc et donc je je suis
une un espèce de vigile comme ça qui dit
[__] faut faire attention quoi parce
que voilà même si euh parce que les les
batailles que j'ai mené judiciairement
qui ont duré 10 années pour moi et que
j'ai fini par gagner euh euh sont des
batailles qui qui sont emblématiques
mais je les ai mené pour pour un
ensemble de de d'autres journalistes de
gens qui qui sont soucieux de cette
liberté et c'était plus important à un
moment donné parce que on m'a souvent
peut-être reproché de de moi j'ai même
plus trop envie d'en parler mais la
raison pour laquelle je me suis battu
judiciairement, c'est pour créer cette
jurisprudence qui existe aujourd'hui et
qui offre plus de liberté aux uns et aux
autres. Simplement, il faut que ça il
faut que ça ça avance quoi. Donc est-ce
que le fait que les journalistes ne
présentent pas les chiffres correctement
ou d'une façon enolée ou
enoleuse induit une forfaiture du
journaliste ou un défaut d'information ?
Mais bien sûr, enfin votre question
contient la réponse quoi. Évidemment
évidemment. la la la presse, vous parlez
de presse économique, disons la la
presse financière est sans doute la
presse la plus
inféodée et qui soit au au aux banques
et au et au groupes financiers. J'ai il
y a il y a j'ai je pense que la presse
financier, enfin le le journalisme
financier, je vais peut-être être
comment dire être lapidaire dans mon
propos, mais n'existe pas. C'estàd que
il y a il y a il y a que des des des
journaux en fait bah prenons les échos
euh ils ess de faire leur boulot mais
c'est c'est quand même pas terrible.
C'est mieux que que certain nombre
d'autres titres mais mais c'est pas
terrible. et et les pages financières du
Figaro comme celle du monde, on voit
bien que derrière il y a des groupes de
pression, des groupes de presse et
cetera et que euh on est d'une manière
générale bombardé d'indices, de
chiffres, de bourses et tout qui sont
complètement falsifiés. C'est-à-dire que
qu'il y a il y a un espèce de grand
mensonge autour de tout ça et je crois
pas au complot, je crois pas à tout ça,
mais je je sais très bien que ces
journaux sont payés par Arnaud, par
Pino, par et par les et par les banques
et qu'il y a des annonceurs et qu' y a
tout ça et que et qu'on peut pas
déplaire quoi. Et je l'ai vu avec
cirstream, c'était le somum quoi parce
que parce que c'était voilà à l'époque
où j' all enfin je veux pas reparler de
ça d'ailleurs je
m'intér donc les législateurs
s'informment par l'intermédiaire aussi
de la presse donc au niveau de d'une
intoxication par un défaut
d'information il y a très peu de
manières pour
s'informer en dehors de la presse misise
à part les blogs. Donc là je vous emmène
sur le les blogs. loi, on on contraint
les blogueurs au même devoir que les
journalistes. On se on est on sera
condamné pareil, on sera jugé pareil,
sauf qu'on a pas de carte de presse.
Comment vous expliquez ça ? Quel est
votre point de vue ? Ça ça ça fait
partie des des des questions qu'on m'a
posé aujourd'hui. Ça demande beaucoup de
temps, beaucoup de Moi, je suis pas je
je pense que toute toute réponse à ça
sera imparfaite parce qu'en même temps,
on peut pas considérer que n'importe
quel pékin qui se met sur internet à
commencer à proférer des injures ou à
raconter n'importe quoi. Euh voilà, il a
il doit être soumis à des à des règles
et à des je veux dire si moi je me sens
diffamé, il faut que je puisse
l'attaquer ou je ça me plairait pas
qu'on me traite de de je sais pas moi de
pédophile ou de ou qu'on invente des
histoires sur moi dans dans dans truc.
Donc je veux dire, il y a il y a
l'internet, c'est pas le fouttoir quoi.
Donc il y a besoin de de de il faut des
règles. C'est comme ça, je veux dire, il
faut des règles pour les victimes comme
pour il y a il y a il y a un problème de
ça. On peut pas non plus dire liberté
totale enfin et cetera. Alors que moi je
suis le plus grand adepte de la liberté
d'expression mais à un moment donné je
suis aussi conscient de de de la
complexité de tout ça. Donc j'ai pas de
solution puisquon m'a interrogé
aujourd'hui là-dessus. Pour moi, c'est
pas une obsession de penser à ça, mais
ce que je ce que je pense, c'est que
c'est que qui ait une une sorte
d'autorité morale, enfin comme la haute
autorité de l'audiovisuel qui
puisse euh comment dire être une espèce
de de chambre de compensation ou de ou
de ou d'instance d'appel quand il y a
des des des problèmes, ça peut peut-être
fonctionner ça. Je suis pas sûr que ça
soit la panassée, mais il y a il y a un
truc à imaginer autour de ça. Je je
m'explique. Euh j'ai j'ai il y a des tas
de gens, je peux donner des exemples.
Il y a des gens qui je me souviens d'un
type qui je crois que c'est dans la
région de Grenoble qui avait fait des
qui avait qui était pas du tout
journaliste mais qui qui qui était je
crois éducateur ou infirmier et qui
passait ses weekends où son temps a
travaillé pour un site et qui avait
filmé des manifes des policiers qui
tabassaient des femmes dans une manife
et les policiers ont porté plainte ils
ont dit que le truc a été manipulé et le
type a été poursuivi, il a été condamné
et cetera. Il avait pas eu de carte de
presse, la commission de la carte l'a
pas défendu et il s'est retrouvé à poil
et sans rien. Ce type, il faut le
défendre parce que euh mal il est
peut-être sans doute plus journaliste
qu'un éditeuriste du Figaro qui écrit
n'importe quoi ou de ou d'un autre
canard. Je dis le Figaro, ça peut être
un canard de gauche, j'en ai rien à
[__] c'est pas ça. Et donc il y a il
y a il fait œuvre de journalisme, il
fait œuvre mais comment mesurer ça ?
Parce qu'à côté vous avez un type qui va
sortir une fois de chez lui avec son
iPhone qui va filmer un type qu'il aime
pas et puis il va inventer une histoire
autour de ça, il va être poursuivi, ça
sera normal qu'il soit condamné. Bah
donc il y a il y a et et comme rien
n'existe, on peut pas tout le temps se
protéger de derrière ça. Il y a un autre
problème, c'est je je suis considéré en
tout cas comme un journaliste où on
m'invite dans les écoles, vous
m'interviez des choses comme ça. J'ai
pas de carte de presse moi. Depuis 80,
on me l'a retiré en 95, enfin en 97
parce que mes droits d'auteur étaient
supérieurs au gains que j'avais dans les
entreprises de presse. J'ai même fait un
un un j'ai été j'ai créé une
jurisprudence au niveau de la carte de
presse puisque j'ai prouvé que des même
si on était auteur donc on m'a rendu ma
carte de presse pendant années puis
après comme j'ai écrit des romans et des
trucs je l'ai plus. Mais donc on voit
bien que de dire qu'un journaliste c'est
uniquement quelqu'un dont les revenus
parce que c'est ça la
définition d'un journaliste aujourd'hui
en France, c'est plus de 50 % de ses
revenus doivent venir d'une entreprise
de presse. Mais ça veut dire que vous
avez des directeurs de com des fois qui
ont des cartes de presse. Moi ça à
l'époque c'est pour ça que j'avais fait
ce ce procès entre guillemets à la carte
de presse. Et vous avez vous avez un
autre débat moi qui m'a hérissé, c'est
toute l'histoire avec Bachelot là et et
la bande de fille là de de direct 8 là
comment elle s'appelle ? Je sais plus.
Ferrari la la la nana plus l'autre enfin
elle et Bachelot a commencé à ouvrir sa
gueule pour dire attendez nous c'est
normal qu'on ait une carte de presse
parce que on fait un travail de
journaliste et cetera la commission de
la carte leur a dit non et alors a
expliqué que alors elle a eu un truc
elle a dit mais regardez c'est c c ces
types sont des tacherons, c'est des mecs
les types de la commission de la carte
comme ils sont pas en pleine lumière
comme nous par frustration il nous
empêche d'avoir la carte et donc elle a
elle a essayé de développer l'idée que
quand on faisait du divertissement, on
méritait la carte de presse aussi. Je
pense que c'est une hérésie quoi. Et
qu'il est normal que ces gens-là, ces
filles-là et ça serait des mec ser
pareil, n'est pas leur carte de presse
parce qu'elles font du divertissement,
parce qu'elle raconte des conneries à la
télé, enfin je sais pas quoi. Et donc
l'énervement qu'elle a eu était était
surfait. Et si elle voulait une carte de
presse, elle avait qu'à faire comme moi,
elle avait qu'à faire une mesurer,
demander une dérogation et et il y
aurait un un jugement. À un moment
donné, il faut décider si des gens sont
capables d'avoir une carte de presse ou
pas. et et je pense que la la la
commission de la carte n'a pas les
moyens de ses ambitions, mais
heureusement que que des journalistes
c'est ces soutiers de l'info ou c'est ou
ces galériens des des types qui en
dehors de leurs heures sont à la
commission de la carte. Heureusement
qu'ils sont là pour tenir un peu la
boutique mais je pense qu'il faudrait
les aider. Je pense qu'il faudrait
renforcer l'arsenal. Alors c'est très
compliqué parce qu'après vous créez tout
de suite un conseil de comme chez les
médecins et c'est pas ce qui est
demandé. Donc il faut trouver il faut
trouver quelque chose une une il faut
euh sur ce qui existe déjà pour créer un
un un ce que j'ai appelé la chambre de
compensation peut-être des journalistes.
C'estàd qu'il y a un endroit où tout ce
qui est litigieux et problématique
puisse être jugé par une sorte de sage
qui serait alors après le problème de
les nommer par des l'Assemblée nationale
les journalistes et tout ça ça crée des
castes, ça crée tout ça. Il faudrait
trouver un moyen démocratique et
accepter par tous de créer cette cette
commission qui soit pas comme la haute
autorité qui est quand même un espèce de
truc où les mecs viennent tirer du blé
parce que parce qu'ils ont rendu des
services quoi. Et donc je trouve pas ça
terrible non plus. Mais il y a il y a
des choses comme ça à inventer. De toute
manière, les la démocratie, on on en est
au début de ces questions là. on pourra
plus faire l'économie de se les de se
les poser. Il va falloir
vraiment mais parce que parce que il va
y avoir tellement d'injustice et il y en
a déjà tellement qui profile que si le
législateur et si les professionnels ou
les les n'essaient pas de de de proposer
des choses et de réfléchir à tout ça, on
va vers des des mini catastrophes qui
vont peut-être en amener des grandes
quoi. On voudrait votre avis sur
l'affaire Snowdon.
Ce ce jeune, j'ai trouvé incroyable que
la France lui donne pas lui donne pas
l'asile si justice mais là on est dans
la géopolitique, on est dans la réal
politique et on est dans voilà, on
s'attaque pas impunément aux États-Unis
quoi. J'ai pas mal lu là-dessus. Donc
j'ai lu des choses assez des choses même
dans des journaux. Je crois que j'ai lu
ça dans Rollingstone où on expliquait
que Stanon était un activiste de droite
qui avait des des propos
complètement on essaie de de qu'il soit
de droite ou de gauche. Franchement je
m'en fous quoi. Ce type il faut lui
donner une médaille comme il faut donner
une médaille à comment il s'appelle
Bradley Maning et évidemment à Sange
plus à Bradley Manning qu'à Sange. Ce
sont des ce sont des il méritent des
prix Nobel de la liberté. C'est des gens
qu'il faut qu'il faut voilà, il faut
leur il faut leur monter des statutes,
il faut les il faut c'est il faut les il
faut les accueillir en France bras
ouverts quoi. Parce que c'est quand même
incroyable que que le type démontre à
quel point les Américains nous ont
écouté enfin d'une manière ce qu'on
savait, ce qu'on subodorait. Mais là on
le lit, on le voit et vous avez ces
espèces de de de types qui frôlent les
murs là. On les voit bien les les types
du pouvoir là quient pas trop se cogner
sur la question quoi. Et et je trouve
ça, je trouve ça moi j'ai voté pour eux
mais je voterai peut-être encore à
gauche évidemment mais c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable et et
ces gens font de la politique mais ils
font pas la politique. Donc ils ont
aucun courage, ils ont aucune et ils
sont en train de de vendre leur âme, ils
ont perdu ils sont en train de perdre
perdre toutes les batailles. C'est
marrant parce qu'ils les perdent de
toute une à une. Je regardais encore
Manuel Val, il y a une vidéo qui tourne
sur internet. 3 4 jours là, il est
interpellé par une femme à à Trappe.
C'est incroyable cette vidéo, faut la
regarder quoi. Val, c'est complètement
minable. Il est minable. il a pas le
courage de regarder cette femme en face
qui dit des choses, des évidences quoi.
Et là, on on voit le le socialisme au
pouvoir à quel point il est compromis, à
quel point il est il est il est il a
peur de son nombre, quoi. Enfin, ça se
passe voilà, c'est il y a un climat de
malaise qui instauré par chez ces
gens-là, quoi. Et vous vous adressez
quand même à eux pour financer votre
projet de chaîne documentaire ?
Mais c'est pas Non, je m'adresse pas à
eux. C'est pas ça. J'ai fait une J'ai
l'idée de la chaîne documentaire, c'està
je passe d'un du cocalan.
Quand je vois les merdes qu'il y a à la
télé sur ces chaînes, quand je vois que
l'argent public ça sert à payer Guli, là
la chaîne des momes ou que que même mon
mom qui est prêt à regarder des dessins
animés japonais, il supporte pas que que
quand je vois que ça va dans France 4
pour des animateurs à la con qui savent
même pas parler français, c'est pas le
problème de parler français où ça paye
des des des séries américaines. avec le
quart du budget d'argent public de ce
truc là, on ferait une vraie chaîne de
doc une ce que j'ai appelé Doc Dog TV,
je veux dire avec beaucoup moins
d'argent, je pense qu'on peut créer un
truc formidable et qui peut infiner et à
terme à moyen ou long terme concurrencer
des trucs comme YouTube ou ou les
projets comme Google TV qui se dessinent
et cetera. Donc, il faudrait créer, j'ai
besoin des Je trouve que c'est normal
dans un dans une démocratie comme
celle-là avec la gauche au pouvoir qu'un
ministre de la
culture puisse puisque c'est des
conversations que j'ai eu avec elle,
puisse aider, ça lui ferait du bien
d'ailleurs d'avoir un bon projet parce
que pour l'instant elle est elle nous
elle défend un certain nombre de d'idées
et cetera, mais je la vois pas avoir des
projets incroyables et ce projet-là est
un bon projet et que de l'argent public
puisse servir à ça, ça me semble juste
et bon. D'autant que je je termine
là-dessus, si vous saviez le nombre de
documentaires incroyables qu'il y a dans
les caves et les poubelles de France
Télévision et d'Arté, vous seriez sur le
cul quoi. Parce que c'est ces chaînes
comme elles fonctionnent avec de
l'argent public, elles ont besoin de c
Je le sais parce que je suis producteur
de doc donc je vois bien comment ça
marche. Les films passent une fois, on
les oublie alors qu'ils sont là et il y
a des tas de gens qui pourraient les
voir dans les lycées, dans les écoles,
dans les facultés. Il y a des des choses
formidables à inventer là-dessus. C'est
pour ça qu'avec mes deux trois copains
euh voilà, Alain de Greff, euh Lyonna,
Bordeaux, enfin euh et d'autres, on a on
a on a imaginé ce ce
ce cette plateforme associée et la vie
de la chaîne de télé, c'est une vitrine.
Donc voilà, l'argent public, oui,
l'argent public, il vaut mieux qu'elle
serve à ça plutôt que de payer des
séries téléaméricaines. C'était ça
l'idée, n'est-ce pas ? une manière de
rester un petit peu euh affilié, voir un
peu inféodé à la politique en cours euh
de se faire enfin financer uniquement
par ce biaislà alors que vous pourriez
également vous faire financer par le
biais du public donc qui sont vos
propres et également mê ça avec une par
exemple une production un peu la
Kickstarter qui permettrait de financer
d'autres documentaires. C'est quoi
voateur pardon en fait vous postez un
projet. Ah oui et selon l'intérêt du
public chacun met un 10 dollars et
cetera. Mais dans le projet c'est de
nouveaux documentaires. D'accord. Ça je
vois ce que je voulais dire. Mais dans
le projet de Dogdc TV il y a l'idé c'est
c'est un projet de film payant très peu
cher mais quand on veut regarder les
documentaires. Donc il y a des vitrines
où il y a des films gratuits et puis il
y a une espèce de banque de données
immense et quand on veut les boire mais
on paye 1 € 2 € on peut s'abonner.
Enfin, il y a tout un système comme ça.
Donc, il y a pas c'est pas uniquement de
l'argent public, mais pour initier tout
ça, le documentaire étant un l'art du
savoir, étant l'art de la connaissance.
C'est pour ça que je pense que ces
documentaires, nous quand on fait des
documentaires, on a tellement de mal à
les faire et on y met une part du cœur,
de l'âme, enfin et cetera qu'on a envie
de les distribuer. Quand moi je vais
dans des dans des lycées ou dans des
universités pour montrer mes mes docs,
les salles sont blindées quoi. Ça crée
des débats, je peux pas passer ma vie à
ça. C'est pour ça que c'est de cette
plateforme, ça pourrait être formidable.
Ceci dit, il y a de telle lourdeur,
Philippe Étier, il est entouré d'énarqu,
elle est entouré de et puis elle a
d'autres choses à penser. Donc c'est
pour ça que je lui ai fait cette lettre
ouverte. Je pense que ça lui a pas
beaucoup plu. Ceci dit, voilà, c'était
comme une bouteille à la mer. Je sais
pas si elle l'entendra. Je pense pas
d'ailleurs. Je pense que il va falloir
qu'on se débrouille autrement. Et donc
là, le net rentre en
jeu. Faire de la pub sur internet pour
une chaîne éducative qui porte des
valeurs, les valeurs de l'intérêt
général, euh ça renforce une population
dans son intellect et dans sa façon de
critiquer. Quand en face nous avons un
dogme journalistique, je prends le dogme
journalistique, le dogme journalistique
économique. Quand les gens apprennent
via Internet, via des documentaires
sérieux par rapport à des économistes
paumés ou finfond de Bercle qui qui
s'adresse vraiment à la communauté de
l'Internet, est-ce que vous pensez pas
que les législateurs français n'ont
aucun intérêt à produire une chaîne
éducative qui pourrait renforcer
l'esprit critique d'une population ?
Non, je je pense que
le comment vous dire il faut se garder
de de de jugements comme ça trop
globaux. Je pense que Vincent Payon est
un meilleur ministre que Luc Châtel par
exemple. Je je préfère je voter je pense
que ce que fait ce gouvernement pour
l'éducation est plus intéressant que ce
que faisait le précédent. En plus moi le
but c'est pas de faire une chaîne du
savoir, c'est c'est de diffuser de
d'offrir une vitrine à des milliers de
documentaires qui sont oubliés. et et je
pronostique, on va pas faire peut-être
des chiffres d'audiences formidables au
début, mais je je pense que que des
jeunes gens, des adolescents ou même des
enfants sont intéressés par la par l'art
du documentaire. Al qu'est-ce que vous
pensez d'un documentaire sur Coca-Cola
qui va mettre à mal des législateurs par
rapport à la régulation de de X
substance chimique ? Est-ce que vous
connaissez l'ampleur de la pression qui
a été faite sur les éditeurs de ce
documentaire ? J'ai entendu parler de
l'histoire. Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur la pression que reçoivent
les réalisateurs de documentaires sur
des sujets touchy qui engagent des
législateurs ? Alors, c'est le le
problème, la question du documentaire
est compliquée parce que en France on
est hyper privilégié. J'ai des copains
espagnols qui viennent en France pour
financer leur film, il y a plus un
centime là-bas quoi. En France, on est
privé parce qu'on a le CNC. Alors, je
sais que c'est très critiqué qui qu'il y
a des castes là-bas, qu'il y a des gens
qui se prennent. Moi je je suis pas un
un je trouve qu'on a une une formule qui
fonctionne et qui est qui est plutôt pas
mal. Simplement, il y a des sujets
casse- gueule et et moi j'ai il y a des
films que je j'ai voulu faire un film
sur Cavana, c'est impossible de faire
financer un film sur Cavana. Je suis
obligé de passer par du crowfunding ou
des choses comme ça. Mais il y a des
sujets et des sujets en France quand on
on traite de la finance comme je l'ai
traité avec Clearstream, quand on traite
d'une l'industrie du nucléaire, quand on
va vraiment au fond du truc, quand on on
est sur les ventes d'armes, quand on est
sur l'agroalimentaire, fait ils font des
trucs pas mal mais c'est souvent des
trucs un peu historiques qui prennent du
temps. Quand on s'attaque à des
multinationales comme ça, Robin l'a fait
avec Monsanto par exemple, c'est le même
problème que alors elle elle a elle a
trouvé un système maintenant qui est
vachement bien, c'est que et ça c'est la
force d'internet, c'est les
souscriptions, c'est-à-dire que il faut
avoir un nom, faut avoir des projets qui
se tiennent et on arrive à financer des
des des choses comme ça. Et le film sur
Coca-Cola, il va être vu. En plus, il y
a des Je pense que c'est un c'est
comment dire ? C'est une évidence pour
moi de dire ça, c'est qu'une démocratie
c'est c'est vous savez c'est des
biorythmes. Une démocratie a besoin
d'information, a besoin de documentaire
et quand on on la on muselle tout ça,
quand on essaie de fermer les vannes, il
y a toujours des endroits par où ça
sort. Donc on va trouver des réseaux de
cinéma indépendants, on va trouver des
et les et il y a internet quoi. Voilà,
ils peuvent rien contre internet.
Pas encore. Ils peuvent rien sur
internet. Non mais ils peuvent rien. Ils
peuvent faire toutes les lois qu'ils
veulent. Je veux dire, on les emmerde
quoi. Ils y arriveront pas.
Le déterminant de l'affaire Kusac, c'est
Kausac. Des types comme Kusak, il y en a
pas. Il y en a pas beaucoup. Cette
espèce d'appelon incroyable avec lequel
les yeux dans les yeux de tout le monde,
il a dit "Je ne mens pas, vous pouvez me
croire et cetera." Il y avait un truc et
je me suis dit ce type c'est je veux
dire moi j'ai je l'ai cru et je l'ai
cru. Alors peut-être j'avais un a priori
par rapport à pleinel. Je sais à quel
point ce type a très envie de tout et
donc je me ça plus à un moment donné,
j'ai dit j'ai un doute moi là-dessus
quoi. Mais après à partir du moment où
il y a eu la bande en plus Harfit un
journaliste plutôt sérieux donc j'ai
j'étais j'étais comment dire j'étais je
me posais beaucoup de questions
là-dessus puis moi je j'enis pas j'avais
des sources de tout le monde et et donc
et l'affaire Kusac au départ le le truc
c'est qu'ussaac quoi quoi. sa
personnalité, cette espèce, je l'ai
encore vu à l'assemblée là, le type est
incroyable, il a un espèce d'aplomb. Je
pense que des causas qui y en a pas
beaucoup dans les dans les dans les
générations de de de politique quoi. Et
c'est aussi ça qui pose un problème.
Ceci dit, vous voyez, c'est c'est un un
formidable parce que Kusac, c'est une
très bonne nouvelle. C'est-à-dire que
s'il y avait pas eu Kausac, euh parce
que euh souvenons-nous de de discours de
François Hollande au Bourger, moi quand
j'ai vu François Hollande au Bourger
s'attaquer à la finance enfin et cetera.
Je trouvais ça pas mal mais je sentais
le gros coup de bluff. En plus c'est
là-dessus qu'il gagne beaucoup les
élections parce qu'en face il avait un
Sarkozi sur l'histoire des banques. Il
était minable he Sarkozy payé par
Goldman Sax. Sarkozy qui va faire le
petit télégraphiste partout. Enfin qui
d'un côté essaie de défendre la France
puis d'un autre côté se vend au
banquiers. Enfin SarkoZi c'était quand
même l'homme des banques. Enfin il a on
dit qu'il a sauvé le système bancaire
mais enfin bon il a aussi enrichi. Enfin
bon et donc en fait vous avez un
candidat socialiste qui ressort des tons
enfin avec un ton qu'on a vu qui était
presque golien et et en fait il a rien
fait quoi. Les paradis fiscaux l'autre
nous a expliqué Sarkozy il y a quelques
années que ça y est il y avait plus de
paradis fiscaux. Mon œil ils sont jamais
portés aussi bien. Et donc je l'ai
écrit, je l'ai dit, je peux le
démontrer. Je peux vraiment vous parler
de ça longuement parce que je connais
bien la question. Et là vous avez
Hollande moi dès le Hollande il en a
rien à [__] de la question des paradis
fiscaux. C'est du discours. C'était une
manière de de d'être au pouvoir. Et là,
le problème qu'il a, alors ils font des
petits trucs à Bruxelles, mais sous
prétexte que Merkel euh leur leur si
s'ils avaient vraiment une volonté
politique forte de lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux, ils avaient ils ont
toute l'attitude pour le faire. Ils ne
le font pas. Il ne l'a pas fait. La
bonne nouvelle de l'affaire USAC, ben il
ne l'a pas fait parce qu'ils sont, je
pense, euh euh liés pas pas d'une
manière euh corruptive, mais que autour
d'eux, il y a tout un environnement euh
euh politique où on voit les les les
liens entre entre la finance tiennent
par la barbichette. Ouais, en gros, en
gros, c'est ça. Mais ce que ce qui est
intéressant avec Kausac, c'est que le
psychodrame Kusac, c'est que pendant 3
mois, il a serré les dents, le mec a
menti à l'opinion. Et puis vous avez
Media Park qui bastonnait derrière euh
PLEL, le procureur général, enfin et
puis Média part a à a à a à fabriquer ce
psychodrame positivement presque parce
qu'à la fin il gagne et le type lâche et
là vous avez quand même un ministre du
budget, le principal chasseur de la
fraude fiscale qui est quand même dans
le leadership du du pouvoir qui qui a
menti. Alors après, il dit qu'il a menti
au président. Enfin, la commission
d'enquête est en train de de de
d'étudier tout ça. Vous avez cet homme
qui explique qu'il a un compte en
Suisse, qu'il a fraudé et cetera, qui
s'excuse et cetera, mais le mal est
fait. Et donc à ce moment-là, la
réaction du pouvoir, elle est assez
bonne parce que comment voulez-vous
qu'il fasse ? Donc il bon, il virent la
brebie galeuse et ils disent "Je vous
promets, la main sur le cœur, on va
changer enfin et cetera." Et ça les
oblige, cette situation les oblige à ne
pas faire que du discours. Donc
d'ailleurs, il entraîne avec avec lui
Cameron parce que Cameron en Angleterre,
ils ont aussi des problèmes. Donc là,
j'ai vu que ça bougeit un petit peu près
de la City mais très vite, vous voyez,
on en parle un petit peu moins. Alors,
on dit qu'il va y avoir puisque cette
histoire de cette histoire de de comment
dire de la communication sur
l'information fiscale d'un pays à
l'autre, c'était en 96 le texte de
l'appel de Genève, si vous le reprenez,
c'était exactement ça. Donc en 96, on
est en en 20 en 30 ans, il s'est il
s'est pas passé 31 ans, il s'est rien
passé quoi de de fondamental. Et là
vous, on a l'impression quand on lit les
papiers et cetera que c'est en train de
bouger, que c'est en train de changer.
Pas du tout. Vous avez deux pays qui
refusent, c'est l'Autriche et le
Luxembourg. Et vous avez la City qui dit
qu'il accepte donc Londres en fait ils
ont pas envie d'accepter non plus. Donc
toutes ces ces c'est-à-dire que vous
avez des embrasements médiatiques comme
ça, puis après vous avez un travail de
fond. Euh à Bruxelles, vous avez euh 3
400 ou 500 lobby bancaires pour un lobby
euh qui est euh on va dire euh
antibancaire, qui est finance watch là.
Mais il y a une force de le principal
pouvoir, c'est quand même le pouvoir des
banques quoi. C'est quand même des gens
qui qui font des holdup permanents et
nous font croire que que c'est nous qui
volons l'argent quoi. Enfin, c'est des
trucs incroyables et le pouvoir se
laisse prendre par ça. Et et les
journalistes aussi. Mais évidemment les
journalistes aussi. Évidemment,
évidemment. Mais c'est pour ça que pour
moi, bon là, je réponds à vos questions
parce que bon voilà, vous m'avez appelé,
je vous connais un peu donc je me dis
"Allez, c'est une heure de mon temps et
cetera." Mais je en même temps, je
trouve ça relativement vain quoi.
C'est-à-dire que je sais on sait je sais
plus ou moins ce qui va se passer quoi.
C'està dire que voilà ce qui va se
passer c'est les affaires continuent
quoi. Et et en même temps moi je crois
au livre, je crois à l'information, je
crois au documentaire. Donc moi mon rôle
c'est d'expliquer des choses et puis
simplement moi je suis un je suis
quelqu'un de je suis la mauvaise
conscience du journalisme un petit peu
parce que voilà pendant 10 ans, je me
suis battu, je finis par gagner mais bon
voilà. Puis en plus, je demande rien
moi. Je m'en fous des médailles. Je m'en
fous de tout ça. Je je simplement je je
pense
que euh que que ma marginalité relative
euh c'est pas moi qui a changé. Moi,
j'ai pas changé. C'est je suis le même
que quand je j'étais à Libération. C'est
j'ai une j'ai une éthique, j'ai une
déontologie, j'ai voilà après j'ai
changé, j'ai j'ai eu plusieurs vies,
j'ai fait tas de choses mais c'est
autour de moi qu'il y a eu des
renoncements, des glissements. C'est le
le le je je je voilà dans un moment en
Libération, il y a eu de la publicité,
après il y a eu des pages de finances,
on nous a dit que c'était l'évolution,
puis on a on a enlevé le courrier des
lecteurs et puis voilà, puis on a vendu
libération à un banquier puis je
continue à le lire d'ailleurs parce que
je trouve deux fois de bons papier mais
on voit quand même que le niveau a
baissé quoi considérablement.
Et justement, vous parliez de niveau
tout à l'heure avec les l'économie, le
fait que les journalistes viennent la
plupart du temps d'un cursus
littéraire ne les empêche-il pas d'avoir
un véritable critique sur l'économie par
exemple sur laquelle ils seront formés
par des économistes mainstream pour le
coup divulguant la Je crois je crois
qu'aujourd'hui un journaliste qui a pas
lu Frédéric Lordon c'est pas un bon
journaliste quoi. Donc je suis pas sûr
que les les mainstream soient et la
coach et les journalistes. Je pense que
le fait d'être littéraire, c'est plutôt
une qualité par rapport mais en même
temps moi j'ai fait j'ai participé à des
sélections de de d'école de journalistes
et je vois bien les les les profils sont
tellement divers quoi. Mais ce qui
frappe surtout, c'est d'ailleurs un des
trucs que je développe dans la série
documentaire que je viens de faire,
c'est c'est la quantité incroyable
chaque année de postulants au boulot
quoi. Vous avez, je raconte dans mon
film qu'à l'Agnon, il y avait 3000 2900
je crois. La qui est unuté de
journalisme en Bretagne. Il y a eu 2900
postulants en 2010 pour 30 postes, 30
étudiants en première année quoi. Dans
et malgré la la journaliste journaliste
la profession la plus décriée en ce
moment aux États-Unis. Vous avez un
journal, il avaient une crise terrible.
les les salaires des journalistes ont
baissé et il y a eu une une étude faite
par un site d'offre
d'emploi qui explique que enfin ils ont
fait un test mais sur un grand nombre de
personnes, je crois qu'il y avait 40 ou
50000 personnes qui ont répondu au test,
c'est-à-dire quels sont les les les
boulots que vous préférez, comment et
pourquoi ? journalistes, je crois qu'ils
arrivent. Alors, il y a les 30 boulots
préférés et il y a les 30 boulots
détestés. Et journalistes, c'est 29e.
Donc, c'est le presque le je crois que
derrière journaliste, il y a bûcheron
dans les boulots détestés quoi. Mais les
mecs préfèrent aller travailler dans le
pétrole, être secrétaire, aller se
prendre une balle en Afghanistan plutôt
qu'être journaliste parce que c'est une
population qui ça gagne pas de sous,
c'est précaire et c'est la merde quoi.
Aux États-Unis. Et en France, on n'est
pas encore là. Il y a toujours Laura,
d'Albert Londres, des des voilà. Mais au
journalistes, vous allez aux États-Unis,
vous parlez de du Washington, enfin de
comment des hommes du président, tout le
monde a oublié quoi. Enfin, faire
baisser les salaires des journalistes,
est-ce que c'est une façon comme une
autre de les rendre encore plus
précaires et de les rendre encore plus
malléable, c'est-à-dire de tendre la
laisse du pouvoir sur leur collier.
C'est ce que a dénoncé Allain Cardo il y
a 15 ans dans son dans un de ses livres.
Allain Cardo, c'est un formidable
sociologue. Euh il c'est lui qui a le
qui a des premier à développer l'idée
des médias workers, quoi. On en est on
est en plein dans les médias workers.
Euh c'est-à-dire euh on est sur internet
sur tout ça, les les papiers plus signés
plus signés par des gens qui sont des
stacanovic de l'info ou les chiva de
l'info qui filment, qui truc, qui
doivent faire trois papiers par jour qui
sont qu'est-ce que vous voulez ? Vous
faites vous faites de l'actualité mais
vous faites pas d'information. Donc
c'est c'est moins le problème des
salaires qu'un que le problème d'un
système quoi. Et je sais de quoi je
parle puisque je suis en train d'essayer
en ce moment de créer un un un un un un
un un un portail internet enfin qui va
s'appeler info du jour où on va on
essaie d'embaucher des journalistes. On
va essayer parce que j'étais parti sur
l'idée que de de l'internet gratuit, moi
marchant sur la publicité et cetera et
et j'en suis revenu, je pense
qu'aujourd'hui devant le d'ailleurs la
la la presse quotidienne régionale est
en train de sombrer et la la presse
nationale est est en très mauvaise
santé. Donc il y a il y a de l'espace
pour un un journaliste de qualité et je
prends le pari que des des les gens vont
s'abonner de plus en plus à des sites
d'information. Mais il faut être bon, il
faut amener une valeur ajoutée, il faut
être sérieux, rigoureux, il faut
travailler. Donc et ça ça se paye et si
ça marche pas, ben ça marchera pas. Mais
en tout cas, on pardon, on va on se
lance dans cette aventure en ce moment.
Enfin, j'y travaille. Dernière question
pour finir, si vous aviez un conseil à
laisser, une bouteille à la mer à
laisser sur internet pour les jeunesses
qui nous regardent, quel conseil pour
affuter leur esprit critique ? J'y
ajouterai une petite un petit un petit
plus. Quel serait le serment du
journaliste en version 2013 ? Le Non,
mais c'est c'est de de de rester
curieux. C'est que l'information c'est
comme une truffe qu'on va chercher quoi.
Ça ça prend du temps. Euh c'est c'est il
faut jamais croire ce qu'on nous dit. Le
on étant les médias, les politiques et
cetera. Mais en même temps, il faut pas
non plus voir des complots partout euh
que journaliste, ça reste un métier
indispensable, qu'on ne s'improvise pas
journaliste, mais par contre tout le
monde peut peut être journaliste à force
de travail et et d'un travail sur soi et
d'un travail de d'acculturation.
C'est-à-dire que pour être journaliste,
il faut être cultivé, il faut lire, il
faut s'intéresser à l'actualité, il faut
lire des livres. Très important la
littérature. Je veux dire, moi je
j'apprends plus le journalisme en lisant
Tom Wolf ou même Richard Brotigan qu'en
lisant des essais. ou des ou des penflés
enfin donc il y a voilà c'est d'une
c'est c'est d'une grande complexité je
je et c'était alors est-ce que je je
pense que c'était sans doute plus facile
il y a quelques années pour pour pour
gagner sa vie en étant journaliste
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est c'est
c'est sans doute plus difficile et
encore je pense qu'on est dans une c'est
difficile en ce moment parce que on est
dans un un monde est en train de
s'effondrer. on si les gens ne l'ont pas
vu, c'est qu'ils sont aveugles. Mais les
quand on est un peu au cœur des
systèmes, on voit bien qu'il y a un
effondrement permanent. Enfin et en même
temps, des choses sont en train de
renaître et et on va arriver sans doute
à une sorte de rééquilibrage parce
qu'encore une fois, une démocratie peut
pas vivre sans information. Alors,
est-ce qu'elle peut vivre sans
journaliste ? Je pense pas. Moi, je ne
pense pas parce que des journalistes
sont les sont les garants de cette
information. Après, c'est sur la
définition de qui ils sont. C'est
certainement pas euh Claire Chazel qui
pour moi c'est pas une personne
détestable, elle est d'un commerce
agréable, mais pour moi, c'est pas une
c'est pas par elle que le journalisme
c'est pas l'avenir du journalisme. C'est
la fin de ce journalisme. Donc il y a
des journalismes qui qui émergent d'un
petit peu partout. Euh mais il faut euh
voilà, il faut hiérarchiser, il faut le
web est une est un est un est un monde
encore en en devenir quoi. Mais il faut
pas oublier non plus qu'aujourd'hui ben
le journal de 20h fait 8 ou 9 millions
de de gens qui le regardent. Les radios
sont très écoutées. Le le net est pas
c'est pas la panassé mais on sait très
bien que dans 20 ou 30 ans, bon ben
voilà, tout viendra de là. tenir au bien
de
rien.
D'ultralibéralisme ou de
libertarisme qui consiste à dire en gros
il y a une main invisible du marché qui
surtout veut dire mais attendez n'ayez
comme seul comportement personnel d'être
égoïste. En fait le prisme c'est juste
un un sous-programme particulier d'un
plan plus général. Autrefois, ça
s'appelait, ça s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans
le un programme que l'on conn qui
s'appelle les Gon.
Alors, les ni les Russes ni les Chinois
n'ont envie que l'ONU se transforme en
une machine à donner les bons et les
mauvais points de gouvernance E
[Musique]